what's going on everybody and welcome to
part five of the Python 3 basics series
in this video we're gonna be talking
about indexes with lists and slicing
because we might as well while we're
here so what we've been doing is working
on this tic-tac-toe game that we're
trying to produce and the next thing
that we want to do is like let's say a
player says they want to play at a
certain position how do we modify that
specific position in our actual game so
what we can use first of all you can use
indexes to get an exact value but you
can also set a value at a specific index
or you could use a slice
so to exemplify this what I'm gonna do
is multi-line comment out what we've
done so far so quote quote quote close
it off here and then I'm just gonna work
right above here and just make some
space so so let's say we've got a list
I'm gonna say L equals and we're just
going to say 1 2 3 4 5 just for quick
reference to reference an index of a
list we can say L and then in square
brackets we put the index so let's say L
1 so the thing that's at the first if
index what should that be well it's
going to be the 2 right because the 1 is
the 0th index so if we were to print
this out we can see ok we get a 2 here
now the other thing that we can do is we
can do more fancy things like for
example we can even do like so what if
we wanted to reference that 5 well the 5
would be at index 4 right but 5 is also
at the end of the list so we could
reference it with a negative 1 so at the
negative first if element of the list
also a 5 we can also reference a slice
so we can reference from the first death
to the third index and you can see here
it is a 2 to a 3 so the first is this 2
all the way up to the 3rd which is the 3
we could go like this or if you wanted
to do ever
thing from a certain point you could say
to : for everything after the second
index and so on there's lots of stuff
that we can do there the next thing that
we can do is like for example we can
print L here and you see it's one two
three four five we can set something at
a specific index so we could say L 1
equals 99 now print L and we can see
it's been modified here now it's 99 so
putting this together with our our game
wherever it is we can let the player
basically when they say they want to
play at a certain position we can use
indexes to do that now this is a list of
lists so at index 0 we're referencing
this part of the list so we'd have to we
could change that to be a single scalar
value that would be a mistake so instead
we actually have to reference inside of
the list of lists what we want to change
so let's say we wanted to change this
number it would be you know game 0 in
brackets and then some more brackets a 1
so let's just go ahead and make that
manipulation so let's run this and just
see what we're looking at cool now if we
just go here and we say game 0 and then
1 so this is 0 and then the first if
index there is gonna be right here this
this position here so we can say that
that is equal to whatever we want it to
be so let's say we want it to be a 1 now
let's run everything so now you can see
yep that one got modified there so
that's how we can set the you know when
a player is playing we can put an X here
you could put an X here by the way we
could say X like that and now you can
see it's a string X I don't really want
to do that because yeah the quotes are
gonna mess things up like I said later
on if you want to make that change and
make it
more visually appealing have at it but
for now I'm gonna do this so everything
stays in pretty line so now now that we
have this what we want to do is start to
let a player play on the game map as
well as like every time we want to make
a change or whatever we want to be able
to display the game map so every time a
player plays we want to show the new
game map and so on and if we wanted to
do that what we would wind up doing is
every time we wanted to see the game map
we would we would have to copy and paste
this little chunk of code well in
programming anytime you have repetition
of a block of code or even if that block
of code is a little bit different if
it's a repetition of a fairly similar
block of code chances are you should
stop that there's probably a better way
either through using some sort of loop
or in this case a function so every time
we want to display the game we really
don't want to do it this way because for
example like if you know here's the
start of the game here and then okay we
want to make a new change so game 0 1
equals 1 well if we want it now we'd
want to like let's say that you know the
player enters that now we want to make
it change we'd have to run this code all
over again right and eventually that's
gonna that's going to be a bunch of like
wasted space in your code it's gonna
make things harder to read and so on so
we definitely want to start using
functions so that's what we're gonna be
focusing on in the next tutorial if
you've got questions comments concerns
whatever feel free to leave them below
otherwise I will see you guys in the
next video